-House Democrats called
on the vice president
to remove President Trump
through the
Twenty-fifth Amendment
as they prepared to vote
on a resolution
to impeach the president.
Meanwhile, Trump emerged
for the first time
since his Twitter ban
and refused to take
any responsibility at all
for inciting a violent riot
at the Capitol.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The House is preparing
to impeach Trump
for inciting an insurrection,
which would make him
the only president ever
to be impeached twice,
who'll also be
the only president
who lost the popular vote
the first time;
in reelection, the second time,
in addition to being impeached.
A record number
of Americans went
to the polls
to boot him from office
and his job approval is now
down to 33%.
His name will be etched
in the Congressional Record
and in history books forever
as a seditionist
and aspiring tyrant
and the worst, most dangerous
president we've ever had.
He could very well
be permanently disqualified
from holding office
in the future,
arrested,
and tried for sedition.
He's been banned from so many
social media platforms,
he's going to have to start
hiding his hateful rhetoric
in Yelp! reviews.
His longtime bank is refusing
to do business with him
and he could even be held liable
for civil damages,
in addition to being prosecuted.
Oh, and his wife
won't hold his hand.
Well, one of them won't.
And, yet, knowing Trump,
none of that
will matter as much to him
as this --
-New England Patriots
head coach Bill Belichick
declining the civilian honor
the Presidential Medal
of Freedom,
with President Trump set
to award it later this week.
Instead, Belichick put out
a statement saying, in part,
"[T]he tragic events
of last week occurred
and the decision has been made
not to move forward
with the award."
-The fallout of the attack
on the Capitol
continues for President Trump,
who has now
lost his relationship
with the Professional
Golfers' Association.
The PGA announced it was moving
its 2022 championship
away from Trump National
Golf Club in Bedminster.
The PGA says holding
a championship there
would be "detrimental"
to its brand.
-Well, well, well.
Once again, big golf tries
to silence conservatives.
First, it's the media;
then, it's big tech;
now, it's famous Antifa leftist
Bill Belichick and the PGA
tearing down our country.
Don't Belichick and the PGA know
that what we need right now
is healing and unity?
How dare they hurt
Mr. Trump's feelings
and the feelings
of 74 million Americans
by taking away his precious
golf tournament
from his private resort.
Don't they know
how much those hardworking,
real Americans love
to sit home on a Sunday
and watch
the PGA Polyester Fashion Show
by a bunch of trust fund
semi-athletes
named Cameron
and Bryson and Brooks?
Taking golf away from Trump
is like taking away
Freddy Krueger's claws.
Without them, he's just a dude
with a messed-up face
who looks bad in hats.
Seriously, though,
you know you're toxic
when a guy who looks like this
thinks you're bad for his brand.
How does he get to games,
tornado?
So that's where things are
for Trump.
Then, today,
he emerged in public
for the first time since losing
his ability to tweet
and, as the nation
continues to process
the deadly insurrection
he incited
and the ongoing threats
from right-wing terrorists,
the president refused to take
any responsibility
for his role in the riot,
choosing, instead,
to lash out at Democrats.
-We want no violence,
never violence.
We want absolutely no violence.
And, on the impeachment,
it's really a continuation
of the greatest witch hunt
in the history of politics.
It's ridiculous.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
This impeachment is causing
tremendous anger
and you're doing it
and it's really
a terrible thing
that they're doing.
For Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer
to continue on this path,
I think it's causing tremendous
danger to our country
and it's causing
tremendous anger.
I want no violence.
-[ As Trump ]
I incited violence,
even though I want no violence,
but, if you impeach me
for inciting violence,
there will be violence.
No violence.
But also,
there will be violence.
We don't want people
to be angry,
but also, they should be angry,
and dangerous.
Anger and danger,
those are the two key words.
No violence.
But anger
and danger and violence.
But hold the violence.
I want no violence.
Seriously, he could've
just gone with,
"Do what I say
and nobody gets hurt."
Seriously, is he trying to get
impeached a third time?
Is he going
for an Iron Man streak
where he commits
an impeachable offense
every day
until he leaves office?
Does he think this is Quiznos --
if he gets impeached ten times,
the eleventh is on the house?
Trump then spoke again
to reporters
before he got
on his flight to Texas
and, this time, he insisted
his speech to the violent mob,
whipping them into a frenzy
and inciting them
to ransack the Capitol,
was actually totally fine.
-So, if you read my speech --
and many people have done it
and I've seen it both
in the papers and in the media,
on television --
it's been analyzed and people
thought that what I said
was totally appropriate.
But they've analyzed my speech
and my words
and my final paragraph,
my final sentence,
and everybody, to the "T,"
thought it was
totally appropriate.
-No, no, no one thought that.
What do you mean,
they analyzed it?
I mean, I heard the speech
and it wasn't exactly
James Joyce's "Ulysses."
If you heard it,
you analyzed it.
Trump is actually doubling down
in defending himself
after inciting an insurrection
against the Capitol.
Just to be clear, in case
it needs any more clarity,
Trump didn't just incite
the crowd,
by telling them
to march to the Capitol
and fight and show strength.
He encouraged and enjoyed
the scenes of violence
and sedition.
In fact, we know,
from new reporting,
that even as lawmakers
and people inside the building
were pleading with Trump
to send help, he refused.
In fact, his aides couldn't even
tear him away from the TV.
-A behind-the-scenes report
on the president's activities
during the riot
that he helped set off.
Multiple sources tell
The Washington Post
Trump was busy watching
the violence on TV
and couldn't be reached,
not even by close allies
in Congress,
calling him desperately,
in fear for their own lives.
-The Post spoke to 15 people
with knowledge
of Trump's actions
during those six hours
of mob rule
and found Trump to be
a man who didn't care,
even as Republican lawmakers
begged him to speak out.
-There's new
Washington Post reporting.
"'He was hard to reach,
and you know why?
Because it was live TV,'
said one close Trump adviser"...
-My God, he's worse than Nero.
At least Nero played
his own fiddle.
Trump would just call one in.
[ As Trump ]
Can we get a fiddler in here?
It's just more fun
with the fiddle.
It's honestly hard to articulate
just how sadistic
and sociopathic this is.
People were calling
and begging him to help
as violent,
right-wing terrorists
were ransacking the Capitol,
trying to overthrow
the government,
and Trump was watching
with all the glee
of Hannibal Lecter digging
into a fresh spleen.
In fact, it was apparently
even worse than that.
According
to The Washington Post,
Trump had not wanted
to include the final instruction
to stay peaceful in his tweet
during the riot.
He wanted his supporters
to disrupt the counting
of the electoral votes
through violence
and, even when his aides managed
to get through to him,
Trump refused to help
because he was enjoying it
so much.
-He was engaging with aides
as this was all going on.
They were interrupting,
telling him
that he had to do something.
They were interrupting,
telling him
that the Capitol was being
overrun by his supporters.
He was well aware of it.
He was watching it.
He was pleased because it was
people fighting on his behalf.
He was pleased
because he liked the scene
and he was pleased
because it was delaying
the certification
of the Electoral College vote,
and those are the reasons
why this happened.
He knew what was happening.
He was back and forth
from the small dining room
where he watches television
off the Oval Office
to the Resolute Desk.
He just didn't want
to do anything.
-First of all, "He just didn't
want to do anything"
sounds like the back of one
of Melania's jackets.
[ Changes accent ]
You leave her alone!
[ Laughter ]
And her, and her!
Your salacious gossip
stops today!
Second, take that in
for just a second.
The president was watching
a violent mob
overrun the Capitol
in an attempt
to overthrow democracy
and install him
as an unelected tyrant,
and enjoying it.
And, even after that,
large numbers of Republicans
stood by him in his attempt
to overturn the election.
But, guys,
Republicans just want unity.
Come on, guys!
They want us all
to gather around
in a drum circle,
with a Hacky Sack,
pass a joint around,
and forget they tried to incite
a violent insurrection
against the United States!
That's what Republicans
are defending
when they refuse
to get behind impeachment.
In fact, as we speak,
the FBI is warning
of even more possible violence
in D.C. and all 50
state capitals;
the Washington Monument
is closed for two weeks,
due to credible threats
of violence;
and the Capitol Police
have briefed House Democrats
on three terrifying plots
to overthrow the government
and Republicans have responded
by doing what they do best --
making themselves the victims.
-Big tech,
launching a coordinated
and kind of a preemptive strike
on the president,
the First Amendment,
many of his supporters --
banning them
from social media permanently.
-The big tech companies,
in banning not just
-Yeah.
-President Donald Trump,
but cracking down
on conservative speech.
-Big tech continues to suppress
conservative speech.
-I lost, over the weekend,
55,000 Twitter followers.
-Republicans have no way
to communicate.
-Imagine that.
You wake up and you're
suddenly unpopular
with the wrong person,
and you can't communicate
and you have
no legal representation
and you can't fly in an airplane
and you can't put your money
in a bank.
-Imagine that.
You take part
in one little insurrection
to overthrow
the United States government.
Suddenly you can't communicate,
you can't fly on an airplane,
you can't wear sandals
to Houlihan's,
and you can't park your BMW
across two handicap spots,
even though you're just running
into the pharmacy real fast
to get your Cialis.
And you can't go to Red Lobster
and stuff buffet shrimp
in your pockets,
even though they're
all-you-can-eat.
The sign never specified
when and where you could eat it!
And, when you skip out
on the check
and tell the waiter you have
a legal right to this shrimp,
based on the Constitution,
[ Bellowing ]
a document you have never read,
he chases you down
and takes your license plate
and calls 911 and tells them
you're a shrimp thief
and the cops come to your house
and confiscate the shrimp
from your fridge
and embarrass you in front
of your stepson and his friends
while they play
"Tony Hawk's Pro Skater" on Xbox
and laugh at you
and call you a shrimp dweeb.
And you say,
"Stop calling me that, Tyler,"
and then, he and his friends,
they push you down the stairs.
Imagine that.
[ Laughter ]
My God!
Are these people whiny,
hysterical lunatics
who never miss an opportunity
to make themselves the victims,
even after a deadly insurrection
at the nation's Capitol.
Like Congressman Matt Gates
and Jim Jordan,
two seditionists
who aided and abetted
the president's deranged lie
that led to this insurrection
and who voted to side
with the mob
and overturn the election,
even after the Capitol
was ransacked.
Gates and Jordan went
on Fox News last night,
not to complain about the
erosion of our democracy,
but to complain about Twitter.
-If they can cancel a president
with a second impeachment
and what they've done
to the president
with the social media platforms,
if they can cancel
a president,
imagine what they can do
to the 75 million people
who supported President Trump
in this election.
That's what's so dangerous.
-These people want to be able
to control what we see
and how we behave and,
to constrain speech in this way,
I think, is very damaging
to the country.
-These two look like a frat guy
and a serial killer.
You guys know my friends,
Axe Body Spray and Ax.
These fools literally tried
to cancel the votes
of 81 million Americans,
but, now, they lose
some Twitter followers
after a violent insurrection
and they're whining
about cancel culture,
pretending to care about unity.
Like Florida Senator Rick Scott,
who insisted that Joe Biden,
rather than
the current president
or any of the Republicans
supporting him,
should be solely responsible
for seeking unity.
-If you go talk
to American families --
I talk to people
of Florida every day --
What do they want?
They want a positive message.
Joe Biden should be excited
about the fact
that he's going to become
the president next week
and should have
a positive message,
but he is a hypocrite.
He says, "Oh, I want unity,
but, I want to call
my opponents Nazis.
You know, I want unity, but,
if you want to go forward
with impeachment,
you know, go ahead."
I mean, this is not
what Americans want.
-Dude, go back
to your [bleep] milk bath.
What about the 81 million
Americans who voted for him?
Do you think what they wanted
was for their votes
to be thrown out by a handful
of Republican congressmen,
something you tried to do,
even after the mob
stormed the Capitol?
I'm so sick of these ass[bleep]
calling for unity
after doing arguably
the most divisive thing
you can do in a democracy,
and that's overturn an election,
doing it after a riot.
And why is it that only Biden is
the one who has to seek unity?
Why don't you do
something unifying,
like resign or apologize
or start every sentence
about tone with,
"No one was more divisive
than President Trump
and I see that now and I feel
terrible for supporting him"?
Is that so hard?
Or how about Fox host
Brian Kilmeade,
who had this to say
about how divisive
impeaching an insurrectionist
president would be?
-By the way, you know
what the theme
to Joe Biden's inauguration is,
and maybe his first four years?
"America United."
Do you know one thing
that can guarantee
America won't be united?
-An impeachment?
-Having an impeachment trial
on a president that's going
to be at Mar-a-Lago.
-I agree.
He shouldn't be at Mar-a-Lago.
When it happens,
he should be in jail
or, at the very least,
stuck in a sand trap,
as the only golfer
in a canceled tournament.
[ As Trump ]
Some help me crawl
out of this thing.
Tiger! Rory?
Phil!
Dorf! Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I knew you wouldn't
forget me, Dorf.
Give me your hand.
Oh!
No, no, stop!
Don't throw more sand
on me, Dorf.
Oh, no, not you, too, Dorf!
Oh, no!
I love "Dorf on Golf,"
but you know
what's really funny?
"Dorf on Insurrection."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know
what else guarantees
America won't be united?
Inciting a riot
to overturn an election.
How about you guys look inward
and take some responsibility
and express maybe a scintilla
of regret for your role in this?
Maybe that would help
foster unity.
I mean, I don't think
we're ever going to be friends,
but maybe we could be roommates
who don't like each other,
but cohabitate,
thanks to passive-aggressively
writing our names on food.
These guys are like
cheating husbands,
who get sued for divorce
and then say, "What?!
You want half my stuff?!
This should be a time
for unity and healing.
It's not my fault your
sister's hotter than you."
The president gleefully incited
a deadly, insurrectionist riot
to overturn democracy,
refused to do anything about it,
then insisted that his speech
was appropriate,
and, instead
of taking even an ounce
of responsibility for that,
Republicans are making
themselves the victims,
as they always do.
The only way to stop this is
to demand accountability,
remove Trump from office,
and try him for sedition.
It won't be too hard
to find him.
Just put out a bulletin for...
-A president that's going
to be at Mar-a-Lago.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.